Spider-Man star Tom Holland is opening
up about hating Hollywood and embracing
his Newfound sobriety speaking to Jay
Shetty on his on-purpose podcast Holland
said that while he loves filmmaking
Hollywood isn't really his thing Holland
told Shetty I really am a massive fan of
making movies but I really do not like
Hollywood it is not for me the business
really scares me I understand that I'm a
part of that business and I enjoy my
kind of interactions with it but that
said I am always looking for ways to
kind of remove myself from it to kind of
just live as normal a life as possible
Holland added that even appearing on a
podcast like on purpose is an unusual
move for him overall Holland's fear
seems to be losing the essence of who he
truly is to The Fame Monster as he said
he's seen friends and colleagues fall
prey to this exact thing he told Shetty
I definitely think it has been an
ongoing thought which is Don't Lose
Yourself I've seen so many people come
before me and lose themselves and I've
had friends that I've grown up with that
aren't friends of mine anymore because
they've lost themselves to to this
business I just am really really Keen to
focus on what makes me happy which is my
family it's my friends it's my carpentry
my golf there's another piece to this
puzzle which is that Holland has
recently embraced sobriety he also told
Shetty that after taking a break from
alcohol it alarmed him when he realized
how much of an influence drinking had on
his overall life I was definitely
addicted to alcohol not shying away from
that at all Holland said that after
doing a dry January a month in the new
year with no alcohol at all he
understood how much he'd really been
drinking before he told Shetty all I
could think about was having a drink I
was waking up thinking about it I was
checking the clock when's at 12 pm it
just really scared me now Holland says
that he simply kept extending his dry
months continuing through February and
on through June and he saw the results
quickly Holland said I could sleep
better I could handle problems better
things that would go wrong on set that
would normally set me off I could take
in my stride I had so much better mental
Clarity I felt healthier I felt fitter
all of this news about Holland comes on
the heels of his Revelation that he's
set to take a break from acting for
about a year after filming his difficult
Apple TV plus miniseries the crowded
room in fact Holland has been quite open
about mental health lately which is
certainly commendable in a June 2023
Interview With The Hollywood Reporter
Holland discussed that he quit social
media not long ago after realizing the
effects that it had on his mental health
and withstanding the constant attention
that comes with Fame especially at a
young age he told the outlet I can't
walk around New York without clicking
cameras everywhere I go and social media
was bringing that outside world into my
house I just had to get rid of it I
needed to get back to reality remind
myself of who I am and where I'm from
and just to live my life as normally as
possible in my abnormal way which is my
career I guess Holland definitely
deserves a breather if he takes one and
if he wants one there's no doubt this
talented thoughtful young performer has
a huge future ahead of him
if you or anyone you know needs help
with addiction issues help is available
visit the Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Services Administration website
or contact samhsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help 4357
foreign